- [Instructor] We're told to look
at the following number line.
In this number line, we
actually have times on it,
so you could even call it a timeline.
We're starting at one o'clock here.
Then we go to 1:15, 1:30,
1:45, then two o'clock.
And it says, what time is
shown on the number line?
So, pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, so the hour I think
is pretty straightforward.
We are past one o'clock but
we are before two o'clock.
So, we know that the hour is
going to be one something.
It's not going to be two something
'cause we haven't gotten
to two o'clock yet.
Now, what is the number of
minutes after one o'clock?
Well, we have a hint here.
It's going to be between 15 and 30.
And where would it be?
Well, one way to tell is if you look
at each of these tick marks,
it looks like they represent a minute.
Let's just count.
If we start at one, we go to 1:01,
two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine,
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15.
Yep, it looks like each of
these tick marks is a minute.
So, we just have to figure out
how many tick marks we are past 1:15.
So, we can see that we
can go from 15 to 16,
17, 18, 19, 20,
21, 22, 23, 24, 25.
So, we're 25 minutes past one o'clock.
Another way you could
have thought about it
is each of these medium tick
marks represent five minutes.
And you can count, one,
two, three, four, five.
So, that's five, that's another five.
So, this time right over here
is going to be five plus five is 10,
it's going to be 10 minutes past 1:15.
Well, 15 plus 10 is 25 again.
So, the time shown on
the number line 1:25.